we live in the world now that's so kind
we we find the kind way around
everything as humans we we want to find
out how to be someone else what we don't
do is we don't go inside
every morning I go for a run that's the
first thing I do every morning haven't
taken a day off of running since
December 2016
wanna soar get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best David Goggins and some of his best
life-changing advice mentor me David so
let's kick it off with rule number one
be brutally honest we live in the world
now that's so kind we we find the kind
way around everything like if you don't
look good I have to find a kind way of
saying I don't like your shirt right
that's not the approach if that's the
approach you're looking for that book is
not for you mmm can't hurt me is not for
you the approach you have to take at
least I took you take whatever points
you want the conversation had to be a
real honest conversation in the
accountability mirror guess what I was
fat don't find a kind word to say that
you know what I've gained some weight
no you're fat when I couldn't read not
like hey you know even learned
disability no I cannot read of a fourth
grade reading level I'm struggling and
sometimes I call myself stupid not in a
way to put myself down so don't take it
like my god those are so hurtful
yeah the hurtful this honest the
conversation has to become an honest
conversation of where you're at mentally
we're mad mentally I look like I feel
like I'm not this I'm I'm falling behind
in school I'm lazy my house is a mess
you have to look at what it is and call
it what it is don't find words to make
yourself feel better because that's what
so we hang around people that make us
feel better that tell us what we want to
hear not what we need to hear and so we
stay away from those people and we stay
away from those people like our internal
dialogue becomes that kind it's okay
it's not okay so that's where it starts
it starts with that accountability of
it's not okay anymore
this can no longer be okay and calling
yourself out for exactly what you are in
exactly how you need to fix it rule
number two be open minded if you walk
into any kind of
event whether it be physical or mental
if you walk in with already putting that
block on your mind if man this ain't
gonna happen people go how did you gonna
turn 35 miles to death badness oh hi G
100 miles with no training because I
went into it not thinking I can't do
this man I went to it with the strategy
I had open mindedness so until your mind
is open to the possibilities that I can
do this you will never be able to do it
once the mind starts to believe it can
be achieved it then only then that it
starts to break down tactically how we
can do this until then you're gonna
always lose also if you want to have
more confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the links are in the
description below you will never learn
from people if we always tap-dance
around the truth everything I didn't
want to do is what got me to where I'm
at today what if I can become someone
that no one thinks I can be and just
that just me talking about that I have
the hair growing up on my arms rule
number three go towards the truth I came
home one night from work spraying for
cockroaches and long story short I
turned on the Discovery Channel and I
saw some guys going through Navy SEAL
training and they're going through hell
week and they're getting their ass just
beat you know in out of the water
guys ringing the bell there was
suffering and I was waiting like 297
pounds and I had to make a change in my
life you know I was at all-time low and
I wasn't going anywhere and I was
exactly what everybody said I was gonna
be which was nothing so I had to make a
change what was it about seeing
suffering that's that's really
interesting and I actually get it but I
want to hear you explain it why
suffering was the thing that triggered
that thought well for me growing up I
came from a horrible background I got
called [ __ ] every day of my life
growing up lived in a small town the
Klan headquarters at that time was about
20 minutes from where I lived the one of
the high ups in the KKK son
behind me in two classes so you called
me [ __ ] a long time I got my first car
they spray print [ __ ] we're going to
kill you on it so I was just an insecure
scared kid and the only way I could find
myself was to put myself through the
worst thing possible and I'm gonna say
the exact opposite of what the world
today's world is saying so we read a
bunch of books nowadays as humans we we
want to find out how to be someone else
what we don't do is we don't go inside
so literally turn yourself inside out
read the book that says like we're
writing a book every day of our lives
but we never read that book every day
we're seeing who we are as people when I
was growing up I I lied for people to
accept me because I didn't accept myself
so I would make up stories so you so
then you would accept me into your world
I would uh everything I did was for
someone else to like me it was until I
started reading my own book about how
pathetic I was as human being I could
blame my dad I can blame kids at school
I could blame having health issues ATD
my mom not being around great mom but
she was doing her thing I could blame a
lot of people and that's the book I was
reading and I put it off on everybody
else it wouldn't so I say you know what
for me to fix this I get a read what the
hell what the [ __ ] is wrong with David
Goggin not not blame anybody read my
books okay I'm afraid of my shadow how
can I overcome that go in and military
get your ass kicked do things you hate
to do be uncomfortable every day of your
life Roger that
I'm not the smartest kid in the world
okay it says somebody saying oh no
you're smart no no I don't say that to
yourself
I said to myself no I'm a dumb okay
Roger that how you get smarter educate
yourself so the things that we run from
we run it from the truth we run it from
the truth man so the only way I became
successful was going towards the truth
as painful and as brutal as it is it
changed me it allowed me to become in my
own right who I am today
rule number four visualize the Andras
I have the ability to see the end before
the beginning even begins and what that
means is I know that to get to the very
end I can see it right now
so before with the buds and I was loose
on the waist I saw myself walking across
the stage at 191 pounds got so I had to
get to get into the door I saw myself
six months a year later wherever is
going to take me to do it I saw myself
walking across that stage getting that
certificate of graduation from buds and
I was able to be there at 300 pounds and
that feeling that I was nowhere near
that feeling I was able to put myself
there a million times
everything that feeling of like my god
that is gonna feel amazing that's what
made me suffer that's what allowed the
pain to be realistic this is worth it I
want to feel for this next 18 must give
me 18 months if I become a Navy City
finally you know just get through but 18
months six months took me 18 that's what
woke me up every morning was I don't put
myself through this much pain and
suffering for a few seconds so it is a
few seconds of joy it's so worth it man
and so people don't get so I'm able to
put myself at the finish line you know I
have no finish line but at the finish
line of an event before I even start
them and say how are you gonna fill it
into this visualizing this is my biggest
tool of life that's why I've been able
to put myself in cold water put myself
in a hundred mile race millions of times
before I've done it and I've able to go
through the race and see I'm gonna feel
at Mile fifty almost to the almost to
the exact exact feeling right so when it
comes up it's no surprise no surprise
I've already done this in many times
rule number five develop discipline I
prioritize trying to win the bad
in the morning so I always win the
battle of mourning so I get morning time
every morning I go for a run that's the
first thing I do every morning haven't
taken a day off of running since
December 2016 I've every day up in the
morning so I also stretch out every day
for about two or three hours every day
I've missed two days and about five and
a half six years so that's just my
routine in about four days a week I'm in
the gym hitting the weights because you
know you can't just be a runner so this
is every single day the the monotony in
my life but this is what builds
discipline you know and not everybody
I'm not telling everybody to do this but
this is my lifestyle this is how I build
self-discipline rule number six thicken
your skin people I said man you cuss all
the time why well I hate to say it the
best way for me to get how I feel across
I can't see and say you know what I went
through hell week and man it was it was
really hard no that takes your damn soul
rips it inside out and then they say now
we're going to start it it allows me to
express where I was at at a point of my
life if I won't give you all of me why
the hell am I here
why how will you learn from me people
take so much offense to me you will
never learned from people if we always
tap-dance around the truth oh god I love
that we tap-dance around the truth by
finding the right words I don't hurt you
because you have thin skin no tighten up
people it's okay
trust me it's okay you might be called
[ __ ] one day it's okay you might be
called some Jewish word or some [ __ ]
or gay word it's okay
let them call you that what are you
going to do now they don't own your life
how are you going to control that now
how are you going to flip it upside down
and say Roger that now I'm going to
harness this and you read about me years
from now how that's the question how are
you going to do that thicken your skin
become more of a human being don't be
afraid
of the reflection in the mirror because
that's all you can be afraid of once you
overcome the reflection in the mirror
you've done it
rule number seven celebrate your
victories you are pretty good about
celebrating the victories along the way
and celebrating yourself I talk about
with my fiancee every single day I
talked about with her two hours today I
said we are grinding so hard that we are
losing the vantage point of what we have
accomplished today we got podcast
podcast interview flying do this do that
like stop stop it's just me and you and
this mom and pop thing that we that
we're doing look at what this book is
that right now it's crazy look how many
people were touching shut shut up in
this think for a second that's the stop
because all we did was talk about this
and this week I don't know enjoy this
for a second let's we have to take time
it rule out with the we've accomplished
that's an evolution for you man huge
huge but it's a very different David
Goggins and even from a couple years ago
huge because you have to where's all
about I wanna keep on grinding that's
not what I'm saying what I'm saying
though is you have to respect what
you've done take a second not live in it
not sit around and say I'm good
sit back and say let me look at the
vantage point now that I'm at we went
there that's why you reset the vantage
point get the tactical advantage if you
get the tactical advantage too quick and
start fighting you gotta take a second
to take observation of where I'm at what
have I done I'm on the right spot I'm
obviously in the right spot right now
now we can go back to fighting I'm rule
number eight the last one before a very
special bonus clip is out work everyone
work out my work ethic from was the
hours I had to spend learning this when
you sit down and you're not smart you
have a disability yeah and you still
want to be at the top of your class I
didn't want us get by what I realized
that I can learn through hard work and I
can beat the valedictorian in school
but I got put in ten hours more a day
than he does you know what kind of
strength comes from that when you're
sitting down that guy that that Valor
Torah study for an hour and you know I
caught you I caught you and I am dumb
but I have the work ethic to catch you
that's where David Ganga's got really
invented yeah was at a kitchen table
with 20 spiral notebooks that were empty
and then three months later yeah they
were full and you can go through that
too I have made my storage and you go
through these Fowler notebooks of your
life and you're like this is how I
learned it's unbelievable there's no
miles it's not about the models is that
having a discipline every day they say
for me to learn this one math problem
it's gonna take me 10 hours and that's
where it you realize do hard work you
can do you can outwork anybody how bad
as they are but that's the part people
don't want to dive into now I've got a
special bonus it from David on how to
take accountability that I really think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video to taking action here we go
question number one what victory do you
need to celebrate this week number two
where'd you need to be brutally honest
with yourself and number three where do
you need to be a little bit more
open-minded so one big thing is
accountability man mmm you have to start
with yourself so what happened in my
life was we start to get I call it like
the rucksack a rucksack is a pack that
you carry in the military and you put
all your stuff in it your radios your
food your water all that stuff you have
to carry in the military that's your
rucksack it's a backpack pretty much as
you're growing up we all have a backpack
most of ours hopefully is empty you know
and what we put in it is all the crap we
go through in life that's what is in the
backpack for the civilians and we carry
it around with us
so what you have to start doing is
realizing that no matter where you're at
in life I got called [ __ ] a lot
my dad abused me you know learning
disability stutters
immaturity insecurities self-doubt so
much crap on top of me
so much stuff I lied a lot to create
friends so people so much stuff was in
my backpack no one's coming back to help
me so it starts with that person in that
mirror you have to realize you are on
your own now and whatever else you
believe in I don't care what you believe
in but on earth it's a very lonely
journey it starts with the
accountability mirror of looking at say
hey my daddy beat the hell he's not
coming back all these things are coming
back I have to face myself and you have
to own all those things that people may
have done to you now it's yours you got
to own it it's yours now to fix the
problems that people did to you it makes
no sense it's not fair I get it
but if you live in that what was me
mentality of guess what my dad did this
to me my mom just did to me people who
believe did this to me you're gonna
always live right there you have to
figure out ways to move forward because
you're not coming back and it starts
with the mirror and I call it the
accountability mirror in the book
if you want more David Goggins check out
the top 50 rules video I made on the hem
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there because
everybody else is most people are weak
the whole thing about comfort zones is
if you live in one for too long that
becomes your norm